who you through Bella be in the next
five minutes I want you to turn me into
a better excuse me vocal warm-ups we can
try we find out wait I doubt my right
funniest spent ami line from the first
two films I really was a fan of your
Becca and Chloe together you're blowing
yeah bad that she sprung that on us when
we were filming that I yeah laughs ow
laughs so this is the first base will we
be going to second base with you guys
that's a no for me
so have fun is your best friend or be a
brand-new Bella half a teen yeah yeah we
have brand-new Bella so we can start
this whole pitch all over
[Music]
wow wow wow wow yeah that wasn't improv
and so I referred to my father's boat as
the fat dingo [ __ ] and then the art
department had to go quickly and change
the back of the boat to be called the
Phantom but do you know what's even
better is that originally they chose a
different improv of yours because they
thought that was gonna be the one that
they chose and put in the movie and they
painted the boat with like dingo
princess or something
mm-hm and they decided later they
preferred fat and go [ __ ] so they had
to CGI do you
[Music]
you
you